crois moi sommes plus femme a priori il
s'agit clairement pas d'une addition
mathématiques le puriste dirais même
sans doute que ces opérations n'ont
strictement aucun sens mais je suis prêt
à parier qu'une fois son organisme
bourbaki ce retombées même ce puriste
finira par admettre que cette équation
un résultat évident est que ce résultat
est le mot rennes et si ce calcul était
en fait rigoureux et si cette
soustraction et cette addition avait
vraiment un sens l'année enfin on a
parlé de world check un réseau de
neurones construit par mick au lof et
ses collaborateurs chez google ce réseau
de neurones construit une sémantique des
mots en associant atoumo un vecteur
c'est à dire une flèche dans un espace
de dimensions raisonnables typiquement
de dimension 3 cents on a vu que wood tu
vécu chercher à extraire une
représentation compacte du sens des mots
à l'aide de techniques qui étaient en
fait similaire à celle qu'utilise sgd
pour prédire si des utilisateurs du net
fixes vont aimer tel ou tel film et on a
aussi vu que world cheikh avait la bonne
propriété de transformer les mots dont
la sémantique était similaire en des
représentations sémantique qui sont des
vecteurs presque collinaires dans le
sens où l'angle entre des vecteurs
représentants des mots similaires est
très faible mais ça on aurait largement
pu s'y attendre
c'était après tout l'objectif de broc
tchèque en revanche la découverte
stupéfiante que mikko lov et ses
collaborateurs n'avaient pas anticipé
c'est le fait que la représentation
sémantique tes mots se manipule de
manière conforme à notre intuition de la
sémantique
en particulier d'après world québec on a
bel et bien l'équation roi - sommes plus
femme est égal à rennes ou plus
exactement
prenons les vecteurs associé au mot roi
hommes et femmes chacun de ces vecteurs
est une flèche et ajouter un vecteur
correspond à suivre le mouvement de la
flèche al'inverse soustraire un vecteur
correspond à suivre le mouvement inverse
de la flèche ça devrait normalement vous
rappeler des souvenirs de collège
bref faisons maintenant roi suivi de moi
sommes suivis de plus femme
cette suite de mouvements correspond à
un mouvement global qui est le mouvement
roi - sommes plus femme est bien de
façon stupéfiante
ce vecteur est à peu près égale aux
vecteurs rennes incroyable l'étrange
espace d sémantique construit par wood
tchèque semble s'être lui-même doté
d'une arithmétique et de façon
stupéfiante l'arithmétique de l'espace
et sémantique semble
isomorphe à notre intuition de
l'arithmétique du sens des mots
c'est vraiment complètement fou c'est
l'une des découvertes les plus
stupéfiants de la recherche en iran
parce que ce en dit long non seulement
sur les machines non seulement sur nous
mais aussi il me semble sur ce que
signifie que de penser penser ça semble
correspondre à des opérations algébrique
dans un espace de sémantique qui est
essentiellement indépendant de l'entité
qui pensent ces opérations algébrique
semblent être les mêmes que l'on soit
humain ou machine il semble qu'à
isomorphisme approximatif près il n'ya
qu'une seule façon de manipuler la
sémantique
je vous propose donc de nous arrêter sur
la chèvre de la sémantique
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on peut
interpréter cette opération de plusieurs
manières
en particulier on peut considérer que le
calcul roi - un homme qui du coup va
être égal à rennes - femme correspond au
concept de royauté ou dit autrement le
roi et à l'homme ce que la reine est à
la femme et cet écart
c'est le principe de royauté d'ailleurs
on peut alors réécrire notre équation
sous la forme royauté plus femme est
égal à rennes ou dit plus simplement
pour devenir reine
une femme doit acquérir le concept de
royautés notre interprétation tout aussi
intéressante est que le vecteur femmes -
hommes correspond du coup un changement
de genre du coup trois puces changement
de genre d'homme vers femme est égal à
rennes en fait de façon plus générale le
changement de genre d'homme vers femme
qui est égale femmes - hommes est aussi
égal à rennes - roy à mathématicienne -
mathématicien à championne - champions
et ainsi de suite
et ce qui est vraiment étrange c'est
qu'il ne s'agit absolument pas là d'un
cas isolé
de la même manière si on effectue le
calcul meilleur moins bon plus mauvais
n'obtient le vecteur pire ou plus
bêtement encore si on fait le calcul
ciao peut réellement chat au singulier
plus chien au singulier ou n'obtient le
vecteur chien au pluriel
alors dis comme ça ces opérations et
djibril cissé additions et des
soustractions peuvent paraître très
mystérieuse
mais d'un point de vue physique ça
correspondrait tout simplement dans nos
cerveaux à une superposition de
plusieurs types de signaux au niveau des
neurones très profond typiquement
l'activation d'un ensemble de neurones
pourrait correspondre au concept de
royautés celle d'un autre ensemble de
norohna celui de femmes et la
superposition des deux signaux à celui
de rennes
alors on pourrait croire qu'il s'agit là
d'un tour de magie spécifique à world
check et bien non ce qui est vraiment
ahurissant
c'est qu'il ne semble pas s'agir là
d'une spécificité d'un algoé que de
machine learning en particulier
puisqu'il fait fuir encore ses
propriétés arithmétique de la sémantique
on les retrouve également dans la
sémantique des données brutes autre que
du texte
c'est ce qu'ont montré des chercheurs
d'indycar reasearch et de facebook en
2016 ce qu'ils ont fait c'est d'abord
construire une représentation sémantique
des images à l'aide notamment de réseaux
de neurones de convolution profond et
d'un modèle adversaire y aller génératif
on parle de 10 6 dyane et je ne rentre
pas dans les détails aujourd'hui parce
qu'on en reparlera plus tard dans cette
série bref les chercheurs disposer ainsi
d'une façon de calculer la sémantique
des images qui comme dans le cas des
mots et des films correspond à une
fonction d'un espace de très grandes
dimensions vers un espace de dimensions
plus raisonnables et il disposait
également d'une fonction inverse qui
prend des vecteurs de sémantique et
génère des images réalistes conforme aux
vecteurs de sémantique et puis ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est prendre plein d' image de
femme avec un sourire
ils ont calculé les représentations
sémantique de ces images ils ont pris la
moyenne des vecteurs ainsi obtenues
intuitivement ce vecteur moyens et la
représentation sémantique d'une femme
qui sourit
et puis ils ont fait la même chose avec
des femmes dont l'expression faciale et
est neutre et avec des hommes dans
l'expression faciale était neutre on a
alors trois vecteurs de sémantique qui
représentent respectivement des concepts
abstraits de femmes qui sourit femme
avec un visage neutre et hommes avec un
visage neutre et j'imagine que vous
voyez où je veux en venir
les trois chercheurs effectuera ensuite
l'addition vectorielle femme qui sourit
- femme notre puce sommes neutres ils
ont ainsi obtenu un vecteur qui
intuitivement devrait représenter le
concept d'homme qui sourit et oui ce fut
le cas et pour le vérifier les trois
chercheurs ont généré des images
conforme à la sémantique de ce vecteur
bien sûr j'en fais d'autres expériences
de la sorte notamment ils se sont amusés
à faire le calcul hommes avec lunettes -
un homme sans lunettes plus femme sans
lunettes
ils ont obtenu femmes avec lunettes et
je tiens à insister que les additions
enjeux sont bel et bien des additions de
sémantique et pas des additions d'image
en effet si on fait ces opérations
directement sur les luminosités des
pixels des images on obtient vraiment
n'importe quoi
de façon stupéfiante l'addition
vectorielle de la sémantique des
intelligences artificielles est en fait
parfaitement en phase avec notre
intuition de l'addition vectorielle de
la sémantique
alors les sceptiques parmi vous vont
sans nous dire que les résultats sont
quand même pas tip top
mais il s'agit là de résultats qui date
de janvier 2016
c'est à dire il ya plus de deux ans ce
qui correspond un peu au moyen âge de la
recherche en intelligence artificielle
à titre de comparaison le genre d'image
générés par les ja d'aujourd'hui ou
plutôt fin 2017
ça ressemble à ça oui cette image c'est
l'image d'une fille qui n'existe pas si
ce n'est dans l'espace de sémantique
d'une intelligence artificielle c'est
quand même complètement fou de se dire
ça est ce que je trouve plus stupéfiant
encore que là on en est aujourd'hui
c'est la vitesse à laquelle on a
progressé au cours des dernières années
j'ai vu la vitesse de ce progrès ça
paraît difficile de ne pas parier sur
des avancées toujours plus
spectaculaires pouvoir révolutionnaire
dans les années à venir
et si je vous dis ça c'est pour vous
tease et les prochains épisodes à venir
qui parleront des impacts sociétaux et
des énormes dilemmes éthiques et moraux
que vont poser et que pose déjà les
intelligences artificielles mais pour
revenir cet épisode j'aimerais revenir
brièvement sur l'analyse du langage et
essayez d'imaginer vers quoi pourrait se
diriger la recherche de la création de
sémantique des textes pour commencer je
tiens à insister sur le fait que à ma
connaissance pour l'instant les antilles
ans artiste elles sont pas mal pour
comprendre le sens des mots mais elles
ont encore énormément de mal à
comprendre le sens des phrases et encore
plus pour celui d'un paragraphe ou d'un
livre dans un cours au collège de france
le neuroscientifique stanislas de haine
suggère que l'apprentissage de la
grammaire est une étape incontournable à
l'apprentissage de la lecture et
d'ailleurs les bébés semblent
particulièrement brillant pour apprendre
une notion intuitive et inconsciente de
cette grammaire après tout quand on veut
déterminer si le mot des permiers dans
cette phrase que je veux dire doit finir
par er ou pas et on a tendance à le
remplacer par le mot vendre ou vendus
dont en moquait agira plutôt on veut
vendre et pas on veut vendus du coup ça
ferait déterminé er et pas et il vient
ce petit exemple montre très bien deux
choses la première c'est que le contexte
permet de structurer la sémantique
la seconde c'est qu'on sait
intuitivement et inconsciemment
quelle est la bonne sémantique à
utiliser au bon moment on sait qu'il
faut utiliser un verbe à l'infinitif
après le verbe vouloir mais on est assez
mauvais pour l'anticiper de façon
consciente et ça ça suggère que notre
appareillage inconscient pour traiter le
langage est incroyablement puissant et
efficace et qu'il suffit sans doute de
lille
pour observer des progrès spectaculaires
chez les intelligences artificielles
malheureusement on comprend encore très
mal le fonctionnement de notre
inconscient mais la recherche avance et
al avance très vite une autre chose plus
fascinantes encore que suggère de haine
en s'appuyant tant sur les travaux de
smolensk c'est que le rôle grammaticales
d'un mot pourrait être encodées dans nos
cerveaux via une sorte de produit tu en
sors yale il se pourrait ainsi que nos
cerveaux us d'outils algébrique
extrêmement puissant pour traiter
inconsciemment le langage ainsi quand je
dis que je veux déterminé quelque chose
votre cerveau a sans doute très
rapidement conclu que les mots quelque
chose correspondent au complément
d'objet direct du verbe déterminée et
que du coup c'est bien moi qui veut
déterminer quelque chose et pas quelque
chose qui veut me déterminer il ya forte
apparaît que pour vraiment progressé
l'intelligence artificielle devra
maîtriser la grammaire des langues
qu'elle cherche à comprendre est que
cette maîtrise de la grammaire
correspondre à elle aussi à des
opérations algébrique autre chose
notable
l'idée d'exploration dynamique de
l'espace des sémantique que permet
notamment la lecture d'un roman semble
correspondre assez naturellement on sait
pts algorithmique de hidden markov
models l'idée est que chaque nouveau mot
ou nouvelle phrase va nous faire
légèrement changé l'interprétation
sémantique du contexte mot après mot le
contexte évolue ce qui correspond à
dessiner une trajectoire dans l'espace
des sémantique est une belle histoire va
typiquement nous faire beaucoup voyagé
dans l'espace des sémantique
enfin dernière chose qu'en est il de la
compréhension de tout un livre là par
contre ça me semble être une question
beaucoup plus compliquée qui va
nécessiter de comprendre comment gérer
optimalement nos mémoires mais là encore
les neurosciences qu'on suggère des
réponses potentielles notamment la
gestion de plusieurs mémoires à plus ou
moins long terme et qui dispose d'
elle-même d'une fonction d'oubli bon
ceci étant dit mes remarques de fin
d'épisode sont toutes assez spéculative
et j'espère très fortement qu'elles
seront rejetés parce qu'il n'y a rien de
plus excitant que de découvrir que le
monde est plus subtil et plus riches que
ce qu'on imagine la mer fin on avait
parlé déjà de sémantique avec notamment
ou au dessus avec et je vous avais c'est
d'imaginer une
sinon c'est artificiel qu'il irait tout
wikipedia est ce qu'elle aurait une
compréhension de la peur qu'ils soient
là même d'une certaine manière que celle
des humains en tout cas ils ont
morphisme prêt quand même le dire en
actes et matic et quand un marais a fait
le lien avec le cas de marie qui une
expérience de pensée en philosophie
imagine un personnage mari qui documente
et qu'il y ait énormément de choses donc
comme unia qui dirait que le texte de
wikipédia disons et marie vit dans un
monde où tout est en noir et blanc et un
moment dans un laboratoire d et un
moment un sort de ce laboratoire elle
voit des images
enfin la loi les couleurs parfois et on
peut se demander si elle découvre
quelque chose sachant qu'elle a à lui
avant cela énormément sur les couleurs
et qui est devenue une experte des
couleurs est ce qu en étant vraiment
exposés à la couleur on n'obtient pas
quelque chose de nouveau alors souvent
ce genre d'argument est utilisé pour
défendre l'existence de khwaja notamment
dans le cerveau humain notamment une
différence entre comprendre et ressentir
typiquement on y réfléchit d'un point de
vue à rigaud rythmique ce qui se passe
ça c'est un peu con à connecter marie à
tout nouveau jeu de données qui avec des
deux types de données qui n'existait pas
avant puisque les cônes de c
je n'avais pas été activée à vendre qui
est nouveau flux de données qui
n'existait pas avant 2 forcément c'est
quelque chose de nouveau qui décernait
refait encore connectés ce flux à la
partie du cerveau qui comprenait les
notions de couleurs et a priori elles
sont pas connectés parce que marine a
pas eu l'occasion de connecter d'avoir
ces neurones qui sont excités et du coup
de connecter sa sont elles s'en servent
autres mais ceci étant dit ce que je
pars ya c'est que s'il veut vraiment
marié a vraiment bien d'expliquer les
couleurs et notamment lu ce que les gens
disaient des couleurs du monde extérieur
tout ça et qu'elle est notamment réussi
à faire preuve d'empathie en imaginant
comment les personnages ont ressenti les
couleurs même si elle ne les a jamais
vus peut essayer d'imaginer voilà tel
truc est toujours rouge tel truc est
toujours vert et mon pari c'est qu'une
fois qu'elle sera exposée à ce monde
extérieur ces nouveaux flux de données
au début bien sûr elle serait pas
comment l'interpréter ce genre de
nouvelles données ou par rapport en tout
cas ce qu'elle a pris des couleurs du
coup ce serait juste des nouvelles
sensations qu'elle n'a jamais connu
avant mais petit à petit elle pourrait a
réussi à faire le lien avec ce qu'elle a
appris avant est connecté en fait une
certaine manière ce qu'elles savaient
des couleurs sera utile et sera lui
permettra de faire le lien avec ses
sensations de couleurs et ça c'est un
peu si vous affichez ce qui se passe
quand je pense au fait du vélo pour la
première fois depuis 20 ans servane hier
on a toute une partie du cerveau qui
sait faire du vélo et quand on est sur
le vélo tout au début cette partie du
cerveau et pas forcément activés et du
coup on n'est pas assez réactif par
rapport à nos sensations sur le vélo et
ouais on croit découvre une certaine
manière le vélo mais tout à coup on peut
faire le lien entre ce qu'on savait de
du vélo et les sensations qu'on est en
train de ressentir sur le vélo et quand
se dire effet finalement tout est
réactivée on comprend à nouveau le vélo
et je parierais qu'il se passe quelque
chose d'assez similaire avec marie et
d'ailleurs à ce sujet je vous renvoie
vers une excellente vidéo mais rendu loi
vraiment incroyable de starter every day
où il apprend à faire du vélo à l'envers
et ouais il ya vraiment ce déclic un
moment où la partie du cerveau qui
connaît en gros la théorie ou qu'ils
étaient
habitué à savoir le faire mais qui n'est
pas activé et quand on arrive à faire le
lien entre les données sensorielles et
cette partie du cerveau il ya eu un
déclic et puis finalement c'est comme si
on avait toujours su faire du vélo
kasha où nous demandent comment je
définis vraiment la sémantique mais en
fait c'est comme l'intelligence
artificielle l'intelligence où la
conscience ce que vous voulez toutes ces
notions en fait elles sont extrêmement
floues quoi de base et c'est extrêmement
difficile de savoir ce que ça signifie
et ce n'est même pas sûr que définition
rigoureuse au tiennent en un livre de
500 pages et même si on arrive à faire
tenir sa bande d'escrocs pages on serait
pas tous d'accord sur ce que ça signifie
voilà donc c'est des mots très très
floues comme la notion de comprendre il
faut entretenir la confiance que j'ai
donné à la semaine dernière ce sont des
notions extrêmement floue et c'est très
difficile de doser et définira
rigoureusement je pense que ça même
aucune utilité ce que je trouve par
contre assez intéressant c'est que on a
une notion intuitive de ce que ça peut
vouloir dire est ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est d'avoir une version
rigoureuse parce que là sinon je vous
parle on se motive béziat ses fonctions
très bien défini hugo rythmiquement
c'est le truc assez des fonctions et on
peut essayer de voir si ces objets
formelle du coup coïncide a à peu près
dans quelle mesure en tout cas ils
coïncident avec des notions intuitif
qu'on pourra avoir de ces notions et
d'une certaine heure à ce que ces
notions du coup plus formelle ne
serait-elle pas plus fiable plus
rigoureuse que nos notions intuitif ce
que son jeu bat la sémantique
intelligence tout ce que vous voulez
donc forcément ça laisse un énorme flou
mais c'est un fou qui me semble à la
fois incontournable et pas forcément
rédhibitoire pour avoir dépensé
pertinente intéressante et amusante
sur tous ces sujets et leur foi que
j'avais parlé de cette traduction
automatique entre le français l'anglais
après 1900 exemple de traduction
mot-à-mot et du cou valentin biloa nous
demandent s'il suffit d'avoir plein de
textes dans
j'ai plein direct dans un autre langage
pour apprendre des traductions de l'un à
l'autre et au final si vous y
réfléchissez et ben c'est comme ça que
fonctionnent les linguistes il à nice
beaucoup de textes et parfois sur
certaines langues très anciennes ils
n'ont pas forcément d'exemples de
traduction beau thermaux et du coup
essayer de trouver des contextes moi je
sais pas exactement comment ils
fonctionnent je pas du tout un expert de
ces questions mais la réponse c'est qu'à
priori
c'est possible ça soit pas si différent
et que certaines structures
grammaticales récurrentes notamment
correspondent à finalement d'une langue
à l'autre
alors ceci étant dit dans le cas de la
traduction du français à l'anglais c'est
beaucoup plus facile parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus de ressemblances
grammaticales entre français et
l'anglais que entre le français et le
vietnamien par exemple route est longue
plus plus farfelues plus bizarroïdes
mais toutes ces réflexions sur la
sémantique vraiment à ces antiques des
images optiques des images c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est mon
conventionnelle a priori ça suggère que
d'observer nerfs il ya des compressions
des données avec une structure
algébrique en plus qui sont assez
indépendante en fait du de la personne
qui pense qu'on s'est donné comme mon
pari c'est que si on prend une langue
ancienne il y aurait sans doute une
façon d'interpréter au moins
partiellement avec un certain degré de
fiabilité
pas forcément très élevé mais plus que
le hasard ce que signifie le texte
ancien et comment on pourrait le
traduire en à terre dans une langue plus
moderne mais bon bien sûr tout ce que
j'ai dis là est très spéculatif et
faudrait vraiment que quelqu'un le fasse
et l'expérience pour en savoir beaucoup
plus et j'espère être surpris ni trop
demande aussi un humain avec beaucoup de
temps et de patience et qu'il irait tout
wikipedia pourrait faire mieux qu'une
lire et qui fait de la sorte
donc c'est une question assez
intéressante aujourd'hui je pense que
l'on fait largement mieux
je pense que dans le futur les ja qui
progresse lui la vitesse avec il
progresse si elles atteignent un niveau
surhumain je conviens que collision
après j'ai envie de réagir à cette
question c'est parce que lire tout
wikipedia ça prend énormément de temps
donc chipayas aujourd'hui je crois c'est
quelques gigaoctets comme ça fait des
milliards de mots en gros titre de
comparaison une vidéo censored la partie
principale de la vidéo à ses 2000 mots à
peu près donc je pense que en gros dans
une journée où je lis pour beaucoup joli
peut-être dit me mo
mo je pense que c'est pas mal pour une
journée de lectures m'ont parfois il est
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus mais bon moyen
de dix mille mots par jour ça fait déjà
pas mal et du coup si j'essaie de lire
tout wikipedia un rythme de 10 mille
mots par jour
il me faudrait dû faire les calculs
allemand il devait faire de tête il me
faudra du coup cent mille jours et sans
mes joueurs c'est beaucoup ça représente
plusieurs siècles du coup un humain qui
lie to me paye en fait mort on peut on
n'a pas le temps de lire tout ip gars
c'est juste trop et ça c'est quand même
une énorme différence entre les ir hindu
enfin je veux revenir très rapidement
sur la cp où il avait dit notamment dans
les commentaires de vidéos précédentes
que ça posait d'énormes problèmes si les
unités d'être à différentes et du coup
vous avez des variations qu'il était
complètement différente selon les
différents les différentes coordonnées
rien aux moyens de résoudre
partiellement ce programme qui consiste
justement à tout simplement art
normalisé des différentes directions de
sorte que les variations typique selon
chaque direction sont égales à 1 alors
après et ça part un peu débile de faire
ça puisque du plus normal tout même
façon du coup à quoi sert la cp si
justement à identifier les directions
principales
en fait si ça reste utile puisque ça
permettrait de reconnaître des
directions qui sont en fait très corrélé
les unes aux autres
donc si on est deux directions qui sont
parfaitement corrélés il vient le nuage
que points ce sera seulement la
diagonale de l'espace et du coup si je
fais la cp sur sa cp me dira de projeter
surnom la diagonale et on verra qui est
qu une seule direction en fait de
baraques sont des données ça nous
permettrait en fait de d'enlever des
des dimensions qui sont en redonnant
tempête qui correspond déjà à d'autres
dimensions
ce qui est amusant c'est que de façon
équivalente ça ça correspond en fait à
étudier non pas la matrice de covariance
mais la matrice de corrélation qui
tiendrait corrélation entre les
différentes coordonnées donc quand on a
fait tout ça c'est à ses partisans mais
ça aussi ses limites dans son sweat dia
c'est moins bien que si on avait
vraiment un espace vectoriel où chacune
des dimensions correspondent elles à des
trucs vraiment avec les mêmes unités et
du coup ça va arrêter vraiment
d'identifier les directions pertinentes
et un autre preuve que ça pose c'est que
du coup la cp dépend énormément de ce
qu'ont choisi de mesurer divination
choisi de mesurer beaucoup de choses qui
me très corrélé et bien le truc qui
correspond à ce qui est mesuré par pas
mal de choses corée va avoir une
importance qui a exagéré par cet aspect
sur la matrice de corrélation ou sur les
dimensions normalisée bref tout ça pour
dire que la cpa quand même ses limites
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
la prochaine fois on va continuer un
petit peu avec ces histoires de
sémantique en continuant à parler de la
sémantique des images notamment on verra
enfin une définition rigoureuse de ce
qu'est un chat en tout cas un chat dans
une image si vous avez aimé ça l'épisode
penser à le lac et à le commenter à le
partager pensez à vous abonner prendre
dans les futurs épisodes merci au tibet
pour leurs dons et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine fois le robot ne
sait absolument pas faire de distinction
entre une phrase dite normale et une
expression figé les carottes sont cuites
de carottes à côte
une opinion qui est inexprimable dans
mon langage et du même coup une opinion
que je ne peux pas penser comme disait
wittgenstein les frontières de mots
langage sont les frontières de monde